So what's the fear with us in this country, are people really concerned?
Radioactive iodine is released into the air and then it's carried by the wind.
And as it's carried by the wind, it's obviously dispersed over time...
...so the dosage decreases and the distance increases.
You think about L.A., it's 5,000 to 6,000 miles away from Fukushima.
So by the time it got to there or Washington State,...
...it's actually diluted down and a lot of it is decayed.
So the actual exposure to Americans from that worst - case scenario is gonna be very minimal.
But do have a plan to be prepared for any emergency.
Know where to meet your loved ones.
You might not have cellphone or Internet access.
You might have to walk to that site.
And at home, have food, water, batteries for your flashlight,...
...but have an emergency plan.
For Health Watch MD, I'm Dr. Randy Martin.